he knows how to transform like when he
shaves that off but the way he looks at
you and he's got that good nose that's
Wendy Williams earlier this month on her
daytime talk show talking about how hot
she thinks Joaquin Phoenix is only issue
here is that Wendy's comments took a
bizarre turn when he shaves off his
mustache he's got a hairline fracture
he's got one of those what he called a
cleft lip yeah my palate he's got this
yeah he's got this yep she poked fun at
the actor's cleft palate lip scar well I
find it to be I find it to be very
attractive
Wendy's controversial comments caught a
lot of heat on line one in particular
Canadian football player Adam big hill
whose son Beau had his lip repaired just
this week on Sunday Adam shared the clip
of Wendy's remarks on Twitter and
demanded an apology on Wednesday Wendy
came through tweeting I want to
apologize to the klephts community and
in Beau's honor our show is donating to
Operation Smile an American cleft palate
and encourage our Wendy Watchers to
learn more and help support the cleft
community
Adam thanked Wendy for her well wishes
her donation and said I forgive you
[Music]